en el vídeo anterior nos quedamos
admirando esta imagen de la vía láctea
vista desde la tierra y nos aseguramos
de comprender que tan enorme es la
cantidad de estrellas que estamos
observando incluso si cada uno de esos
puntitos fuera solamente una estrella
tendremos una cantidad enorme de ellas
pero muchos de estos puntitos son miles
de estrellas así que nuestra mente ya
estaba asombrada con estas cantidades
pero como veremos en este vídeo esto
apenas es el comienzo y ya voy a dejar
de hacer estas analogías con las
partículas de granos de arena en un
campo de fútbol porque va a llegar un
punto en el que las partículas de arena
se vuelven tan vastas que nuestra mente
no puede llegar siquiera imaginarlo pero
comenzamos con nuestra vía láctea como
vimos en el vídeo anterior nuestro
sistema solar se encuentra a 25.000 años
luz del centro galáctico y tiene
aproximadamente 100 mil años luz de
diámetro en nuestra galaxia y ahora
pongamos la en perspectiva con el grupo
local
y cuando hablamos del grupo local nos
referimos al grupo local de galaxias
esto de aquí es el grupo local de la vía
láctea aquí estamos nosotros a 25.000
años luz del centro de la galaxia y
tenemos aquí algunas pequeñas y pongo
entre comillas la palabra pequeñas
porque estas son entidades grandes pero
tenemos estas galaxias satélite que
están bajo la influencia gravitatoria de
nuestra galaxia pero la galaxia grande
más cercana a nosotros es andrómeda esta
de aquí y esta distancia de aquí a
partir de ahora vamos a estar hablando
de millones de años-luz esta distancia
de aquí es de 2.5 millones de años-luz
y para que se den una idea o tengan una
referencia aunque no se pueden dar
muchas referencias a esto un año luz es
aproximadamente el radio de la nube de
oort y pensemos que un radio de la nube
de oort es aproximadamente 50 mil o 60
mil unidades astronómicas la unidad
astronómica es la distancia que hay de
la tierra al sol así que podemos ver
esto como 2.5 millones por 60 mil más o
menos por la distancia del sol a la
tierra así que este es una distancia
inimaginable y esto es solamente para
llegar a la siguiente galaxia grande que
tenemos cercana aún cuando estas cosas
son cosas enormes con incontables
estrellas pero andrómeda en particular
si habíamos comentado que la vía láctea
tiene de 200 a 400 mil millones de
estrellas se piensa que la galaxia de
andrómeda tiene
un billón de estrellas y aquí estos
números ya se nos hace difícil
imaginarlos pero no nos vamos a detener
aquí este diagrama de acá tiene una
longitud de cuatro años luz
si fuéramos de extremo a extremo
tendríamos y no no son cuatro años luz
son cuatro millones de años luz cuatro
millones de años luz cuatro años luz
sería la distancia del sol a alfa
centauri que sólo le tomaría a la nave
voyager 1 viajar 80 mil años para llegar
ahí
aquí tenemos 4 millones de años luz un
millón de veces más que la distancia del
sol a la estrella más cercana pero aún
esto y se me complica encontrar palabras
para describirlo incluso esto es pequeño
cuando estamos hablando de distancias
intergalácticas si nos alejáramos más
podríamos ver a nuestro grupo local que
se encuentra aquí y esto de aquí es el
súper cúmulo de virgo cada punto de acá
es al menos una galaxia pero podrían ser
más de una galaxia y el diámetro de aquí
es de 150 millones de años luz 150
millones de años luz
así que lo que vimos en el grupo local
del diagrama anterior es que la
distancia de la vía láctea a andrómeda
era de 2.5 millones de años-luz pues
sería un puntito chiquito como éste esa
sería la distancia entre la vía láctea y
andrómeda y ahora que estamos viendo el
súper cúmulo de virgo que tiene 150
millones de años-luz de longitud pero no
terminamos aquí podemos alejarnos mucho
más
y detener nuestro super cúmulo de virgo
de 150 millones de años luz este
diagrama que acabamos de ver
voy a tratar de mantener ambos diagramas
en la pantalla este diagrama representa
150 millones de años-luz esto cabría
justo acá en este otro diagrama y estos
son todos los supercúmulos que se
encuentran cercanos a nosotros y
nuevamente aquí la palabra cercanos la
pongo entre comillas porque es un
término que tomamos un poco flexible
esta línea de acá tiene una distancia de
150 millones de años-luz
mil millones de años luz estaría más o
menos por acá mil millones de años luz
sería más o menos de aquí a acá y aunque
nos hemos estado refiriendo a escalas
masivas esta es aún mayor pero aún no
terminamos en este diagrama que vemos
cada uno de estos puntos y esto quiero
que quede muy claro no son estrellas ni
siquiera a cúmulos de estrellas cada uno
de estos puntos significan cúmulos de
galaxias cada una de esas galaxias
tienen cientos de miles de millones de
estrellas incluso billones de estrellas
esta es una escala tremendamente masiva
pero aún no terminamos
esto tiene aproximadamente 1000 millones
de años luz de diámetro pero esto de
aquí es el mejor estimado que tenemos
del universo visible y en futuros vídeos
hablaremos con más detalles sobre lo que
es el universo visible si nos alejáramos
lo suficiente todo este diagrama de aquí
de mil millones de años luz de diámetro
que habría acá justo aquí
así que estamos hablando de un espacio
tremendamente pequeño esta parte de acá
y esto es apenas el universo visible
quiero aclarar aquí que esto no es el
universo completo es solamente lo que
alcanzamos a ver con nuestros
instrumentos le llamamos universo
visible porque esto es lo que sucede
piensen en un punto aquí afuera y lo
estamos observando digamos que está a
13.000 millones de años luz de distancia
está a 13.000 millones de años luz y
hablaremos más de esto en otros vídeos
años-luz y siento que es casi un
sacrilegio estar escribiendo aquí encima
de esto porque la complejidad de lo que
representa esto es inimaginable pero
este objeto que se encuentra a una
distancia de 13 mil millones de años luz
su luz está apenas llegando a nosotros
la luz salió de esta estrella
aproximadamente 13 mil millones de años
así que de hecho estamos observando este
objeto muy cercano a la época en la que
comenzó el universo la razón de que
llamamos a este universo visible es que
quizás hay objetos más lejanos pero su
luz aún no nos alcanza o quizá el
universo mismo y vamos a hablar de esto
más adelante se está expandiendo tan
rápido que esa luz jamás nos va a
alcanzar así que aquí hay una
interrogación enorme el poder conocer el
tamaño real del universo algunas
personas podrían decir bueno es que esto
no importa ya que esto por sí solo es
algo enorme y quiero dejar en claro que
a lo mejor ustedes dicen bueno si esta
luz de acá ha viajado 13.000 millones de
años para llegar a nosotros y esto otro
de acá también está a 13 mil millones de
años luz de distancia se puede decir que
todo lo que podemos observar o de lo que
podemos observar su pasado tiene un
diámetro que es de
6000 millones de años luz pero incluso
así tenemos que tener cuidado recuerden
que el universo se está expandiendo
cuando esta luz fue emitida y vamos a
hacer un vídeo dedicado a esto ya que la
geometría es difícil de visualizar
cuando esta luz fue emitida en donde nos
encontramos en el super cúmulo de virgo
dentro de la vía láctea donde nosotros
estamos estaba mucho más cercano a ese
punto estaba en el orden y quiero
asegurarme de darles el dato correcto
estaba a 36 millones de años luz
estábamos muy cercanos al menos hablando
en escalas astronómicas
estábamos solamente a 36 millones de
años luz de este objeto cuando salió esa
luz de ese objeto y conforme la luz se
acerca a nosotros y el universo se
expande nosotros nos estamos alejando de
este objeto si se imaginan todo este
espacio y todo se está alejando
y solo 13 mil millones de años después
esta luz nos alcanza pero todo el tiempo
lo que sucedía esto este objeto también
se ha estado alejando así que el mejor
estimado que podemos tener de la
ubicación de este objeto partiendo de
cómo es que se está expandiendo el
universo está en el orden de 40 o 45 mil
millones de años estamos observando el
lugar donde fue emitida la luz en ese
momento hace 13.000 millones de años
pero quiero que quede claro esto donde
estamos observando esta luz es un lugar
muy primitivo el área del espacio en
donde se emitió esta luz ahora se ha
condensado en digamos una estructura
astronómica más madura si lo vemos desde
otro punto de vista las personas que
estuvieran en este punto en el espacio
se han alejado ahora 46 mil millones de
años luz cuando ellos observen nuestra
región en el espacio no nos van a ver a
nosotros
van a ver a la tierra como es ahora
verán la región del espacio donde se
encuentra la tierra en una etapa muy
primitiva poco después de la gran
explosión y bueno el término poco tiempo
después lo uso con bastante flexibilidad
aquí estamos hablando de cientos de
miles o incluso millones de años
hablaremos más de esto en futuros vídeos
pero el objetivo de este vídeo es que se
me hace difícil explicarlo porque va más
allá de lo que puedo imaginar incluso el
vídeo anterior sobre la vía láctea era
difícil de imaginar ahora que estamos
viendo una realidad en la que
simplemente la vía láctea se vuelve algo
casi increíblemente pequeño algo
increíblemente insignificante cuando
vemos imágenes como ésta lo que más me
impresiona es que si alguien me dijera
esta es una imagen de todo el universo
esto solito pondría las cosas en
perspectiva pero aún no sabemos qué es
lo que hay más allá de esto
hay estimados que dicen esto podría ser
un 1 por 10 a la 23 de todo el universo
o incluso podríamos decir que el
universo es más pequeño que esto que es
algo interesante de pensar pero vamos a
dejarlo aquí ya que no importa cómo lo
veamos esto va a sobrepasar nuestra
imaginación incluso antes de grabar este
vídeo estuve observando algunas de estas
imágenes y de hecho ha sido uno de los
días menos productivos que he tenido
porque me he quedado absorta pensando en
lo que estos puntos y los puntos de los
puntos representan